why don't I know you I'm new I just
moved here from Africa what I used to be
homeschooled wait what my mom taught me
at homeo no no I know what home school
is I'm not so you've actually
never been to a real school
before shut
up shut up I didn't say anything
homeschooled that's really interesting
thanks you're like really pretty thank
you so you agree what you think you're
really pretty oh I don't know oh my God
I love your bracelet where did you get
it oh my mom made it for me it's
adorable it's so fetch what is fetch oh
it's like slang from England so if
you're from Africa why are you white oh
my God Karen you can't just ask people
why they're white could you give us some
privacy for like one second yeah
sure
okay you should just know that we don't
do this a lot so this is like a really
huge deal we want to invite you to have
lunch with us every day for the rest of
the week oh it's okay coolness so we'll
see you tomorrow on Wednesdays we wear
pink why do you wear your hair like that
your hair looks so sexy push back Katy
will you please tell him his hair looks
sexy push back Regina was dangling Aon
in front of me on purpose I knew how
this would be settled in the animal
world
but this was girl world your hair looks
sexy pushed
back and in girl world all the fighting
had to be sneaky that was awesome H lip
gloss hey good job Africa thanks Katie's
blushing oh my God you totally have a
crush on that guy no I don't that's why
you wanted to join the mathletes
mathletes you hate math look how red she
is you love him and he totally
complimented you that is so fetch
Gretchen stop trying to make fetch
happen it's not going to
happen why should Caesar get to stomp
around like a giant while the rest of us
try not to get smushed under his big
feet what's so great about Caesar Brutus
is just as cute as Caesar okay Brutus is
just as smart as Caesar people totally
like Brutus just as much as they like
Caesar and when did it become okay for
one person to be the boss of everybody
huh because that's not what Rome is
about we should totally just stab
Caesar gr and Wiener's head
cracked if you even knew how mean she
really
is you know that I'm not allowed to wear
hoop earrings right yeah 2 years ago she
told me that hoop earrings were her
thing and that I wasn't allowed to wear
them anymore and then for Hanukkah my
parents got me this pair of really
expensive white gold hoops and I had to
pretend like I didn't even like them
and it was so sad and you know she
cheats on Aaron yes every Thursday he
thinks she's doing SAT prep but really
she's hooking up with Shane Omen in the
projection room above the
auditorium I never told anybody that
because I'm such a good
friend
Regina we have to talk to you is butter
a carb
yes Gina you're wearing
sweatpants it's
Monday so so that's against the rules
and you can't sit with us whatever those
rules aren't
real they were real that day I wore a
vest because that vest was disgusting
you can't sit with
us the sweatpants are all that fits me
right
now
fine you can walk home
that's where you're going fat
[Music]
ass oh God you dirty little liar I'm
sorry I can explain explain how you
forgot to invite us to your party Janice
I cannot stop this car I have a curfew
you know I couldn't invite you I had to
pretend to be plastic buddy you're not
pretending anymore you're plastic cold
shiny hard plastic curfew 1:00 a.m. and
it's now 1:10 did you have an awesome
time did you drink awesome Shooters and
listen to awesome music and then just
sit around and soak up each other's
awesomeness you know what you're the one
who made me like this so you could use
me for your eighth grade Revenge God see
at least me and Regina George know we're
mean you try to act like you're so
innocent like oh I used to live in
Africa with all the little birdies and
the little monkey you know what it's not
my fault you're like in love with me or
something what oh no she did not see
that is the thing with you Plastics you
think that everybody is in love with you
when actually everybody hates you like
Aaron Samuels for example he broke up
with Regina and guess what he still
doesn't want you so why are you still
messing with Regina Katie I'll tell you
why cuz you are a mean girl you're a
here you can have this and want a
prize
and I want my pink shirt back I want my
pink shirt
back hey hey settle down all right hey
no you do not push
and
do you have anything else you want to
say oh no I can't answer any more
questions until I have a parent a lawyer
present Miss
Smith whoever wrote it probably didn't
think anyone would ever see it I hope
that nobody else ever does see
[Applause]
it
Mom C can you pick me up I'm
scared Janice Ian dyke that's original
you get a function hey that's only okay
when I say it did you write this no I
swear then you told somebody she told
you little you're a
yeah take your top
off now here's what we're going to do
we're going come quick
they've gone wild the girls have gone
[Applause]
wild it was Full Tilt jungle
Madness and it wasn't going
away I pulled these two off each other
coach car step away from the underage
girls let me help you down there who
hell no I did not leave the southide for
this oh crap my hair oh junior girls
report to the gymnasium
immediately oh my God it's your dream
come true diving into a big pile of
girls
okay yeah um I've got an
apology so I have this friend who is a
new student this year and I convinced
her that it would be fun to mess up
Regina George's life so I had her
pretend to be friends with Regina and
then she would come to my house after we
would just laugh about all the dumb
stuff Regina said and uh we gave her
these candy bar things that would make
her gain weight and we turned her best
friends against her and then uh oh yeah
Katie you know my friend Katie she uh
she made out with Regina's boyfriend and
then convinced him to break up with her
oh God and we we gave you foot cream
instead of Face Wash God I am so sorry
Regina really I I don't know why I did
it I guess it's probably because I've
got a big lesbian crush on you suck on
[Music]
[Applause]
that
[Music]
[Applause]
Regina Regina wait I didn't mean for
that to happen to find out that everyone
hates me I don't care Regina please
Regina stop do you know what everyone
says about you they say that you're a
homeschooled jungle freak who's a less
hot version of me yeah so don't try to
act so innocent you can take that fake
apology and shove it right up your
hair
and that's how Regina George died no I'm
totally kidding but she did get hurt
some girls say they saw her head go all
the way around but that's just a rumor
some people swear they saw me push her
in front of the bus that was an even
worse
rumor